welcome to this video playing clunk
clunk from the US let's see let's see
okay this is sometimes called the weight
defense Bishop g4 its provide okay for
blankets not not a bad line okay it's
playing it with the quick g6 okay let's
see okay so it didn't take on f3 when he
had the opportunity to do so I mean the
opportunity to do it when it was when it
was worsening my pawn structure um what
about night age for system move let's
try it I mean it's kind of asking the
black Bishop we're just supposed to go I
am okay so he's trying to he's freeing
his his bishop I mean giving him some
retreat um queen bee three maybe mm-hmm
now that's probably not leading to that
much okay still do it yeah what ideas
move like c5 here attacking be similar
so I saw is retreating voluntarily okay
I'm going to go d5 the only move that
makes any sense IAM until we'll go back
to the seven yes mmm so a for probably
intending a five otherwise the whole
thing is not leading into anything not
sure that that leads to much but
otherwise it wouldn't make any sense
what I played okay um unhook b8 who is
ignoring that that is surprising I
didn't think that this was possible to
ignore
so a five-night c4 on 94 94 95 Quincy 50
maybe this is just about playable it
doesn't look great maybe a displayable
Bishop e3 may I Bishop b3 and then the
95 is a thread young yeah let's do that
94 95 is just good for wide and I have
rook see one in the mix wow really
didn't this just good for right I mean
what am i overlooking here I'm
threatening looks in one here takes
Queen tags check and then looks you one
next check this must be excellent for
right now this rook probably is more
precise so that I have be three how I
see not losing a piece now p 3 sp3 a
six-win before he's not trapping the
queen or anything don't don't see it
let's let's see what sir black resigns
yeah I guess so I just losing the piece
i played this very quickly around here
which i didn't really mean nights the
force it's really a problem yeah wyd
wins fled out after this move yeah I
mean black has to castle or something
like that like this and then we just
have a game I mean I like white here due
to the space and so on but it's nothing
nothing special really happening he has
Quincy fault so if I do this for example
Quincy for is a possibility but ok I can
retreat and get this in and
five now I mean white still has the
space and it's not so clear that those
pieces are positioned in a good way
probably white has a little advantage
anyway he also has lost some time you
have Bishop g4 bit should be six Bishop
d7 and so on it it seems somewhat better
but here there is really no way to
defend it if you go see I just attack it
and then the night is gone so we have a
real opening disaster okay hope you
enjoyed it thanks for watching